okay so the other day yannick and i
played around with openai's codex for
the first time and you can just see our
visceral reaction to it i mean i was
giggling like a schoolboy it was
genuinely very exciting and very
entertaining
my position hasn't changed since we did
the gpt3 video i mean as far as i'm
concerned this is just exactly the same
thing clearly it's been trained on
code so it's slightly better at code and
even though you're sampling the language
model with a temperature of zero it sort
of like reliably gives you decent code i
think it's very entertaining but i can't
really see myself using it as a
as a kind of experienced software
engineer
would my mother want to use it to write
some software maybe i think the kind of
software it creates is only the kind of
software you would want to use in a
throwaway context i think it wouldn't
help you write enterprise grade software
so yeah um i think it's quite fun but
not that useful
but um
we edited the video as well so what you
can't see from the video is that 90 of
the time we were fixing errors i've only
showed you really the fun bits and this
is what i've noticed online on these
codex videos is that you only get to see
it working
and there's a real selection bias there
because i can promise you ninety percent
of the time it's not working anyway i
hope you enjoyed the video
see you soon so we still got that
javascript darren
we've got four
okay
suddenly it doesn't seem as easy
let's make a um a 12 by 12 grid
make a 12 checker
colored something like this
nope
we're now in full web dev debugging mode
so this is the grid see so this is the
grid oh there's just nothing in it yet
okay
put a
letter into each cell
make every other cell black
no way i mean that almost yeah almost
it starts at 65
and it always correctly indexes into the
grid right even with
the cholera no this is not
it interprets as checkered
yeah
color the grid like a chess board
wow yes
amazing
amazing crazy yeah
so we want to have a character
that can traverse the grid cells and it
needs to look like a pokemon
an
element
to the first grid cell
picture of a pokemon
no way
that is incredible
[Laughter]
wow when the user presses
the arrow
the arrow key
the pokemon will go in the pokemon
will move on the grid
no way
i think that's going to work
oh wow
no it's just it worked once but okay it
worked once
crazy
crazy see how i get i get errors
okay when i press arrow keys yeah yeah
so what's it done then so it said
yeah i guess it doesn't find the pokemon
again but in any case uh it's pretty
impressive pretty cool every time the
user presses
an arrow
then the pokemon travels
to the adjacent cell in the grid
great
it would just refer to just the
the pokemon on the like
yeah so now
it
doesn't exactly work but you know
wow
i'm going to guess it registers multiple
events or something the grid will still
have loads of event listeners from
before can you control the arrow keys
okay yes nice
um
say
when the element intersects
the walls it turns blue
oh no i can actually not cut
okay
um
let the user control
the element with the arrow
now i can okay
i i just controlled the scroll bars
before
so yes say say it goes blue when out of
bounds
no a critter
mouse out
they said mouse out listener
ah oh interesting
not what we wanted but no
say as it travels
um it accelerates or something
it goes faster no nothing
no i don't think so
oh there's a mouse move now
let's kill that because
because yeah
it
downloads
the current stock data and then we have
to go a bit longer right about
5 12.
there's a plot there's a main function
yeah so
not sure can i run this
so that's the bitcoin price
every second no way
i'll be
seriously impressed if it gets done
okay so
let's see um complete ah just makes more
examples
whoa
is that what it did i mean
it's wrong but it looks kind of
interesting should i if i expect you to
try to execute this um no way
yeah i mean it's completely wrong
it's adding the potions to your health
points this is your example 20 and two
solution nine
solution five
no yeah
no
yeah that is horrendously wrong he tried
interesting try the the other one now
this one's a little more interesting no
it's still still completely wrong five
no wait i didn't see
three and twelve
yeah no it's just obviously you
laughably wrong it's supposed to be
looking at the first order differences
well
there's something here every price in
prices
take the minimum price and price that's
just meaningless maybe you have to
formulate it i don't i don't know how to
give you formulated
well now we get into the loops yeah i
was getting so excited about codex and
now the uh the reality is setting in
you yeah we're using it wrong yeah your
goal is to write the program i think you
need to write it as if it appears in
code right
implements
an algorithm that
will find
the
two elements
that are closest to each other in a
list
maybe not index out of range okay it
doesn't work
but a good try they could design a sql
table
i want to design a sql table where there
are products and customers
now we can you can go on right you can
say
implement a
sorry a product
paid the class with name
price ql table for the above
there is a product there are the
purchases with foreign keys oh it gets
sql insert statements
yeah we've got some question marks
every track
it could be in i don't know 128
languages
and it needs to be sparse
let's say there's a translation for
every language and you want it to be
sparse so it only
records the translation for that
particular language not all of the
languages which should be sparse yeah
but here look it does it does like it
does it even with the sql alchemy right
so now here's the locale
yeah i'm not sure exactly what this uh
track id like um
then you have the language but then you
have all of this stuff i'm not sure if
that i think that has done what i've
asked though so it's going to create for
a track for a locale it's going to
create all of the title and everything
so it's done it okay that's pretty cool
well
it just
it just imports all kinds of support
vector machines
implement an svm to predict whether the
bitcoin
price
will go up next week
hey
reading data do you have cleaned rock
drop some columns
random seed 42
try and test split
scale the data
create svm model
hit
predict
accuracy compute well it's just done
like a standard
standard sem like
it has essentially nothing to do with
the with the bitcoin price right so
you'd have to get that data somehow say
john carmack's fast inverse square root
what is yeah
yeah
yeah explanation
no way that's pretty good it's basically
from wikipedia traverse
my documents folder
and find a file that
contains two consecutive a's in the
name okay
json
[Laughter]
interesting
i mean that's kind of useful recursively
yeah
okay
well now it's just
comment mode again
no
no but
it uses a different method
now you grab it
thank you searches
to the panel which will add a customer
to the database one click event
there's no oh customer in your html
that's brilliant after
after 10 customers have been added
delete all the customers
okay
well
no
but delete customers works but it also
deletes the buttons so
okay why don't we start again and let's
have the notion of a data store
customers and their products create a
function that
can add a
to the data store
well well that's
that's i guess real life
how do you do data store in javascript
right well um why don't you say create
creator
create a customer's data structure
that's pretty good
every customer has
a name
a customer number
a unique customer number and a location
it's pretty good now um
create an array to store the customers
in okay and um add a customer
called john who lives in sacramento
quite impressed if it gets this wow
that's fine yeah that's pretty cool
display the customers on the panel why
don't we add the like a text box
on the panel to add a new customer to
the data store add a text box and a
button to create a new customer
see where it gets that
no way
nice that is pretty
see
number three location
this doesn't do anything yet was there
an event when a user click
submit
perform yeah add the list and update
the list
display yeah
great
so press the add button yeah
no you did okay
it's definitely called oh no there's an
error okay
i don't even i don't you need to specify
what the function does you see this
on the right it like already implements
this function that pushes the new
customer that's crazy this this submit
thing is not called so
how about
i can do this manually i guess equals
submit
event listener click ok
so now
yeah
say um add a delete button for every
customer
yeah
no way
look at that look at that
it worked once now
is pretty impressive
in some ways i could see how this could
be
really good
yeah it's just unfortunately not good
enough
something magic you know every now and
then we've had a taste of wow that's
really cool
but the reality is it wouldn't save us
any time i would just displace the
location itself that's what happened so
what do we do with the map of great
britain
okay so now um underneath the map
display the population of great britain
no no it doesn't no it's just it's just
changing the inner html
well
okay it does set timeout but this should
be set to interval now yeah
now say
now say um
alternate the color from blue to green
every second
well the image color is i mean
we need to actually like css recolor or
something
you'd say using a filter yeah it's
changed the color but it's only done it
once how about this
yeah yeah yeah yep when the player
clicks the ball
it should fly towards the goal this is
doing some kind of calculation
certainly certainly some
stuff
what the hell does it do nothing much
just a bunch of like computing some
all on click add gravity
the ball is affected by the gravity but
it goes to the right
well
see now where the gravity goes to the
left no
say the ball chases after the mouse
cursor the mouse enters the ball
it should start chasing i mean this is
good right
it has an on mouse uh move event can we
make a pendulum um a square
like a pendulum oh hello we can
we can but it's not a pendulum that i'm
i want to have a circular pendulum pivot
on an axis come on
come on
[Laughter]
this is brilliant
like a
we need to make a snooker game a snooker
okay
add a background that is the table
in full high and width and green
able is green
no yeah of course it's stupid yeah
he actually made a table describe the
ball
in the abstract let's create six balls
break a club for a
ball and then say create six balls
of
random colors and we want to make the
balls
um
round with a filter make the balls round
let's say round first
me oh that looked quite good have we not
got a balls array yeah we do
so now this should add them to the balls
yes no actually they are here they're
just oh okay
each ball
yeah okay brilliant right so now
um we'll give them all a random velocity
and
when they intersect they should bounce
off each other boss collide
they
should bounce off each other well i
don't know if that worked
well this is like a collision though
wow okay damn
okay so this doesn't work when two balls
collide look at that
they turn red
why don't we model a force of gravity
between all the pairs of balls is there
something happening i thought so i could
detect something when the balls
intersect each other
one of them disappears
that's great naked party well a party is
certainly taken literally you can see
that
here we need to change
this to let's say
uh 400x right
and like 300 why
because it's probably not good at that
yeah so you're crazy
go crazy what does it do it speeds it up
when they intersect the hole the ball
disappears add a
small black hole the ball is
deleted and make the hole have a
gravitational pull well the hole
disappeared
interesting only bounces off yeah you
see
we did earlier so it only affects new
balls it's basically gbt3 awesome
so um connor what's your take on codex
unsurprising would be the one word i
would use to describe it i guess
it's definitely cool like you know just
playing around with it it's cool it's
fun it's more visceral i guess for a lot
of uh you know engineering and software
development type people to kind of have
something that you know isn't their
domain quote unquote but ultimately it's
not it's kind of what i was predicting
was going to happen even gpt three you
know it was not trained on code at all
had truly phenomenally terrible
tokenizer for code like if you try to
tokenize code often it will tokens every
single white space in the indentation as
its own token very often so you'd have
these ridiculous you know
encodings of code so it makes sense that
there's a lot of like really low hanging
fruit to have there so i definitely
think it's its current state it's fun
it's interesting
copilot seems genuinely useful to me i'm
not sure about i mean codex is kind of
like it's kind of like the basis for
product copilot is a product copilot is
something you can use it's like uh i
haven't used it much myself yet but
everyone i've talked to who's used it
said it's great for just doing the
boring stuff that would have taken you
know half of your day and now you can do
it you know
20 faster which in itself is already
really useful yeah what about from a
software engineering point of view so
when i was playing with codex with um
with yannick
we were in the sandbox and it was really
really good when you were building
things up from scratch and
at first they even abstracted away the
temperature parameter and all of that
because you know
i almost couldn't believe that we were
talking to a gpt type model
it just magically produced the right
code and it just seemed to work first
time but how would it be different in a
software engineering context
so i mean obviously you have to know the
limits of these models what what they
were trained on what they're good at
they're really really excellent at you
know like
basic boilerplace code using standard
libraries it's uh you know
writing simple things that there's like
clear examples of on the internet so you
know there's lots of examples for like
little games where you know walk on a 2d
grid or something there's lots of
examples like that around the internet
so i'm not surprised that's like really
good at doing that specifically
the so from that perspective the biggest
use is that like you know a lot of
programmers of course you know
rightfully or not uh say that you know
the most hardest part of programming is
like it's not writing the boilerplate
which i agree with obviously you know
often you have a huge code base with
thousands of lines of code but only like
you know 100 of them are like really
difficult or like you know really
important and the rest is just
connecting to a database and you know
setting up your you know type checking
all your data or whatever but even like
so
i don't think this is going to lead to
like a huge revolution you know
right now at least of how we do software
engineering or something but even if you
can you know if you're a big corporation
you know you hire you have two thousand
software engineers and you can make them
all ten percent more efficient writing
boilerplate code that's a big deal like
that that's the i think that's the um
intended use case for stuff like copilot
we shouldn't think it of like okay cool
pilot is gonna you know is going to
abstract away my star haskell developer
and his you know genius programming of
course not but you know your your code
monkeys that you know are writing you
know javascript boilerplate or whatever
um
if you even make them 10 20 more
efficient that's really good
of course the future i think is you know
uh things start um kind of you know
not so big yet so far things are still
pretty modest you know okay get 10
efficiency here i i like you know i
don't want to speak about you know is
this going to be cost people jobs i
don't know probably not or at least not
many but the future i think is going to
be different
i think codex is kind of one of the
first signs of this it's still a toy to
a large degree like or at least these
like playground things are like you know
you get a little thing to walk around
the grid that's cool but you know it's
not revolutionary but i think the future
as these models get better and better
you know just can't draw a straight line
at some point in future
um i can have a run i can you know
create an app or a startup or something
just by talking to my computer like that
you know i just give it natural language
instructions i want to create an app
that does this and this and it has this
property or whatever and the models will
figure that out they can't do that yet
but i think the
i think if we just extrapolate out where
it's pretty obvious that it's coming
interesting
yeah
one of the things that janik and i did
was we made a customer database so we
said you know i want to put a customer
in the database and i want to have a
form to add a customer in the database
and remarkably it worked quite well but
the kind of code it produced was quite
um
hacky i mean it was it was setting the
inner html property for example on an
html element it's doing all the kind of
stuff that you that you're normally not
supposed to do
if we were doing it in real life we
would have some kind of enterprise
framework or we'd use an mvc product or
something or actually if i was inside
google they have their own custom
end-to-end framework they have their own
kind of software engineering is all
about modularization and finding a kind
of information architecture to fit your
problem so that wouldn't necessarily
exist in uh you know codex's memory bank
yeah absolutely like as i said like i
think you shouldn't think of codex as
replacing product managers
but it's uh as supplementing the people
who you know the to the product manager
manages i don't think he's replacing
them either we're not there yet as you
said you know you sometimes you have
like you know specific demands on how
the code is supposed to be structured or
what libraries are used but that those
seem like solvable engineering
challenges you know you know companies
could have you know bespoke models that
are set up to understand the kind of
coding style they use or the libraries
they use it all seems like you know like
sometimes i i jokingly say that
large models kind of feel like alien
artifacts that kind of just drop from
the sky one day and we're still banging
rocks against them and trying to make
them do something useful that's kind of
how you feel about codex codex obviously
knows a lot of things about um code you
know of course all the symbolisms are
going to come running and say it doesn't
actually understand but i'm i'm not
trying to make a philosophical point
here i'm trying to make like a practical
point like you can you it obviously is
capable of generating
some useful things and it's much better
than all previous systems and if this
continues to extrapolate which i think
is a good null hypothesis to have if it
continues to improve you know just this
is the very first time any product like
this really has been built at this scale
and this level of capabilities
if you just extrapolate that further who
knows how much performance you know we
might get out of these things and how
clever they might become and how useful
they might become once we figure out
that maybe natural language is the wrong
way to interface with them you know
maybe
you write in the future you write specs
in some kind of domain specific language
and then these models figure out what
you mean by that
and maybe the domain specific language
is not formal so it's not like a so like
something it's somewhere in between a
formal language and natural language or
like it's like
it's like natural language but but
annotated with some kind of you know
descriptive or whatever and that gives
the model enough hints that it can write
like really good things or maybe you
just write tests and then using the test
it will you know extrapolate what the
code is supposed to look like
we're really just the beginning of
trying to understand you know what the
correct way is to build systems or using
this kind of technology
body tuber actually was full of praise
for the system he couldn't believe that
it worked so well on a diverse set of
languages i mean admittedly we edited
the video so he probably wasn't aware
that 90 of the time we're fixing
javascript errors and fixing problems i
think this is a problem actually with a
lot of the examples of codex online is
it so much more entertaining to show
when it does work
absolutely um
the key question though is um
to what extent is it just
interpolating stuff it's seen on the
internet now i know i know your answer
to this right because i could go down
the whole oh it's not doing any
abstractive reasoning and your response
is to say well actually it doesn't need
to there's so much regularity out there
in terms of the kind of code people
right you can interpolate
it is it is an information retrieval
system but so what that that actually
does exactly what we need it to do i
mean i would argue that
i have yet to see any convincing
evidence that you know humans do
something that isn't very similar like
have you seen high school students do
math problems have you seen like
beginner programmers program it's not
that clever
sure like some
geniuses you know have done something
for a very long time they might figure
out really really clever things but i
think it's kind of an unfair comparison
to to compare literally the first system
of this kind we've built and say oh wow
why can't it invent its own dialect of
haskell man this is such a weak system
sure i i think um
like recently on twitter i i
retweeted a funny thing where it's like
you know those class examples where you
give people like a question it's like
four plus four times zero equals and
then like half the people i saw
yeah loads of people got it wrong
yeah
there's this there's a kind of implicit
like
almost like status or like or like uh
repeatedly related implications of words
like interpolation or it's just
memorization
that's the just does a lot of the heavy
lifting here in my opinion is that i
think sufficiently sophisticated
interpolation or sufficiently
sophisticated memorization is
indistinguishable from intelligence
interesting well um
i'm trying to come up with a good
example so jeff hawkins spoke about um
albert einstein for example so the
reason why he was able to solve or come
up with this idea of general relativity
was he could analogize it to everyday
objects that we all understand and then
he could use that to communicate that
understanding to other people and then
jeff said you know when when it came on
to the the field
equations it was a completely different
story there weren't everyday objects to
analogize it but there does seem to be
something that we can do with our
reference frames
of understanding that allow us to
traverse between different places and
concept space in a way that you clearly
can't do with the neural network i don't
say that's clear at all
gpd3 can make some really great
analogies
go up
i mean it's just like you know i've seen
many people try this work just like you
give examples like you know x is to y
like zed and you just give it a bunch of
examples like that and some of them are
pretty clever all of them absolutely not
again have you listened to humans lately
most people are not einstein and in many
ways you might argue maybe einstein just
you know got lucky like you know for
every einstein we have a survivorship
bias for every einstein there's ten
thousand schizophrenics that think
they've you know discovered the theory
of everything and are completely dead
wrong about everything and you know make
like inferences about that like i think
there's a saying in engineering that um
often it's easier to understand how a
system works when it's not working
correctly so i think it's really
interesting actually to look at like
people that suffer from like mental
illnesses or whatever and how like i
don't know if you've ever like you know
the classic you know online you know
schizophrenic ramblings and how much
it's like a model with the too high
temperature parameter or that is making
like weird analogies that don't actually
work or like like insists on like using
specific
keywords like very heavily and then like
draws analogies that just kind of seem
completely out of control it's like
again it's there's this question of
um if something is sufficiently
sophisticated that it can do everything
a human does
is there still a difference like you
know if something i'm not you know
whether gbt models scale to human level
intelligence is an open question i
consider that an empirical question
about science that we do not know the
answer to the answer may be no that's
absolutely possible it might be we hit a
role there's something there's something
about how you know humans the algorithm
works they're like fundamentally
different from gradient descent and
there's no possible way you can get
there that's definitely possible but
i think there is a lot of heavy lifting
being done by words like just or clearly
or obviously i don't think these things
were obvious at all it was not obvious
like i feel like every person that says
it's obvious these things will not just
scale should show that they predicted
that gpt3 would work ahead of time if
you predicted that neural networks would
scale to precisely gpt3 performance and
no further before gpt came out i i'll
give you that but i think that most
people wouldn't have predicted gpd three
ahead of time
well that's very interesting i think you
could argue that intelligence is
multifaceted because i know you have a
view of intelligence as being very kind
of um from a decision theory point of
view so in terms of making an optimal
decision in any situation and i think a
lot of people invoking this analogy
making is the coral cognition
it might be something which is very
intrinsic to humans so it's a function
of the topology of our brains and the
function of our embodiment and how we
interact with the physical world so
albert einstein because of the way in
which he learned the information and the
order in which he learned the
information he had a certain topology in
his brain and he can then traverse that
topology maybe that's something that
gpt3 can't emulate but maybe gpt3 excels
in another facet of intelligence that
perhaps we don't
yeah that's where it's important to kind
of de-reference the pointer to
intelligence intelligence is a word and
it points to things and an important
thing about how humans use words is that
we don't
don't always point to the same things
even so we use the same words like some
people when they say intelligence they
mean like very specific things they mean
like symbolic reasoning or something
that's a very specific thing that you
can talk very specifically about other
most people point to like kind of like a
vague intuition like there's like agents
and they have like they kind of like
they can like have like thoughts and
goals and optimize sort of other people
point towards you know like specific
tests or whatever so it's kind of
important to differ to reference the
pointer and kind of understand what are
we talking about when we use the word
intelligence someone can try to avoid
using it when possible so
ultimately i think it's like it's we
should use our words as tools is that
when i use
the word intelligence what am i trying
to accomplish with this what am i trying
to what am i pointing to which concept
do i care about of all possible things
intelligence to refer to what i
personally care about is the ability to
solve problems is that obviously in our
world there are entities which we can
pretty reliably point to as being
intelligent and being able to solve
certain problems like we can point to a
rock and say that's definitely not
intelligent and we can point to a human
and say yeah that's definitely
intelligent there's some things in
between where i like insects or like you
know animals were like is that
intelligent maybe kind of depends on how
you appoint it but there are like some
clear examples and there are some things
and there's but there's many things that
humans have that rocks don't and vice
versa you know it's like so
the way i see it is what i care about is
is that
um the these systems can solve problems
that they can solve very hard problems
that a rock can't solve like there are
there are situations where i want a rock
you know i'm building a wall i want a
rock to just sit there i don't want it
to you know spontaneously have goals and
start walking away um there are other
situations where i want to hire somebody
and i don't want to hire a rock i want
to hire someone who you know can do the
job and solve the problems i can have
and
then
so that's the other meta discussion then
you have the in the discussion of like
okay but what is the thing what is the
thing
is it symbolic reasoning is it
some kind of specific algorithm is it a
class of algorithms and i don't know
obviously i don't know how the brain
works and i don't know how unique the
brain is and how it works there might be
you know there might be you know many
ways to skin a cat there might be many
ways to achieve performance but you know
made have a very alien architecture and
like like if an alien came to us from
the you know and from a seventh
dimensional you know universe and it
looks at the world around it's
completely incapable of functioning like
it's like where are the other dimensions
i cannot function and it's just
completely stupid it falls over and dies
is that thing intelligent or not in our
universe it just falls over and dies but
in its universe maybe it was the
einstein of its universe it figured out
the seven dimensional you know equations
so it's not super simple to define
intelligence in that way so i try to
focus more on the practical aspect is
like
these models in some sense have become
much
better at things that we would
traditionally associate with
intelligence 10 years ago you know we
could barely understand the picture
barely play go you know barely do any of
these things nothing like gpt3 nothing
like codex all this is very far away i
think there is some sense in which these
mods have become more powerful
can i formalize that not really but i'm
not sure about how important that really
is
interesting no you're so right though i
think when we um invoke the word
intelligence straight away we we have a
very anthropocentric conception and also
if you've been listening to jay mark
bishop he's dancing with pixi's reductio
he has this thought experiment that even
a rock has an infinitude of conscious
experiences but that's far too
philosophical for now anyway conor
thanks so much for coming on i really
appreciate it right as always so just
like a bank job um dr kilcher what's
your take on codex
um
i don't think it's ready yet for
what they advertise it as
uh so my experience i guess our
experience was that
you probably
still need to be able to code to make
use of this tool at all because
it can produce code
but you have to
read it you have to make sure what it
wrote is correct
and you have to
uh know how to edit the code if
something's not right in addition to
that if it doesn't do what you want you
often have to reformulate yourself
um so for example if it's like check if
two balls intersect when you have like a
game where two ball like balls fly
around it would
sometimes just check once like right now
do two balls intersect then you have to
reformulate like uh make or continuously
check whether two balls intersect or
create a function that checks whether
two balls intersect and then
continuously run that function so
you have to
uh almost like be a programmer
in order to interact with the system
properly
so there are some things that it's i
feel it's uh very bad at
namely
like lead code algorithm questions i
i don't think it's like
it's a it's it's a quite a ways away
from that
uh you know give me
for two lists give me the elements that
is larger than the blah blah blah and
the mean of the blah blah blah no
however there are things that it's
really good at
namely
almost like the boring things of coding
so
create all sql statements for a
particular data model it's we've we've
seen it be like extremely
competent at that right you give it the
data model right you say i have a
customer it has a
name and and and sort of a basket of
items and then the items are products
and they're in stock and whatnot and it
would even understand the foreign key
relations and all would just create your
sql statements for you
uh yeah that's i think that's that's
pretty beautiful and those are
the parts of coding that no one wants to
do like 90 of java code can probably be
just automated because
don't have to write the stupid getters
and setters and and and whatnot right so
that that kind of stuff
i think it's really good at also in in
web programming
when you you know you wanna you wanna
like do a form that has some fields
uh even with the best libraries nowadays
it's still kind of a pain
so
that kind of stuff i totally see it it
being applied to
do you believe though that there is a
lot of regularity to reality because
connor said basically that
everything you'd ever want to do you
know intelligence basically isn't as
smart as we think it is it's all out
there and if you interpolate over it
then you can do everything you need to
do but i know that you work in a legal
startup and that's a great example i
think it's quite instructive because we
would love to automate the legal
profession i mean god they're almost as
annoying as accountants but you can't do
it right because every situation is
novel and similarly when i need to write
a piece of code it doesn't necessarily
look like things that are out there it
always seems novel
well the legal profession in particular
is special because it requires
judgment
right a lot of legal people think of the
law as this sort of algorithmic thing
that you can do but it's very often it's
not that very often
the law contains language of judgment of
reasonableness of uh
just just just sort of
you have to live in the actual world in
our time in order to make sense of the
law
which you can't
a
an algorithm you can't expect an
algorithm to to be able to do that it
can maybe
sort of replicate some stuff
but not particularly much when it comes
to coding though
you know a lot of people code
by going to stack overflow and sort of
mishmashing together code
and
i'm pretty sure you can get codex to a
level where you can achieve the same
thing
where you as a human essentially act
sort of as a selection machine for what
codex produces
and if they make it a little bit more
user-friendly in that it cannot only
produce code but it can maybe
refactor or you can say look here are
three pieces that i have from stack
overflow please
put them together
make them go together um i think
something like this is certainly
certainly doable
yeah
i don't know whether many people know
this but i'm also building a startup
around a software code review as a
service
and it'd be quite cool if rather than
generating the code you could use it to
um scrutinize the code because i guess
you know from a software engineering
point of view
you can't trust generated code right
because it's it's probably full of
security holes so at some point either a
human or an algorithm needs to check it
well
i don't know it depends on how it was
generated right like for a lot of stuff
i'd rather have generated code than like
you know i'd rather have my compiler
right assembly
than a human
so
like it depends on what
what's you know what the task is and how
confident you are in in the machine and
i
i think this might be the same as with
self-driving cars there might be tasks
in which these machines perform again
and again and again and again just so
flawlessly that with time
you just accept that they make less
mistakes than humans just empirically
right
and they're going to screw up every now
and then but so does a human right
in fairness as well a large class of
error modes
are laziness it's because the humans
probably knew how to use that design
pattern or they probably knew they
should have checked that um
that security key into the uh you know
they should have put it in a config file
they shouldn't have checked into the
repo but they just couldn't be bothered
yeah
awesome yeah
that's it's i i don't i don't think
there's there's too much of a clear cut
right here i think that the state that
codex is in is not yet
ready for pretty much anyone to to use
right now um
the examples are kind of cherry-picked
and
but i see the potential like there's
there's clearly a potential there not
too far away for something like this to
be quite useful be it for generating or
as you say just analyzing a piece of
code and just red flagging all the weird
things
walid sabbah was impressed
that that is wow i've not seen that yet
i know i'm fairly sure that open ai will
get even more investment now that walid
tuba has just given it the
awesome um doctor culture thank you very
much
thank you lovely doctor suburb we've
been playing around with codex
um what's your take on it does it just
remind you of gpt3 very much so i mean
it's uh
essentially it's the same
for the lack of a better word same
paradigm basically
it obviously
[Music]
it has digested
millions of lines of snippets of code
from all over
impressive that it covers many
paradigms and and platforms
from sql to python to java classes and
objects so very impressive
and
i guess that's the magic of
connecting openai with microsoft now
they got github
which obviously means they got
billions of lines of code
from
i was like a few places going like wow
look there this is cool right so
impressive uh would it would it really
finish the job no can can someone
actually use it that's a big question i
don't know
probably
uh it reminds me of uh the old case
computer aided software engineering
where
you also had drag and drop and the
classes were generated for you i mean
you had some really nice tools
uh
but
it impressed me more than gpt 3 on the
language side because on the language
side i
uh you're matching language to language
i mean here you're matching language to
code
it's it's very very like
wow i mean
uh you it seems like you're programming
in natural language
it's
it's just uh
uh
very cool to see i i really commend them
on this one this is very impressive
uh yeah uh i i know you might be
surprised with this reaction but you
gotta give the guys credit this is
this is an amazing uh
uh accomplishment i mean
uh
very impressive i'm i'm i'm surprised
you can easily i'm surprised that you
would be so positive yeah because if
anything my position is exactly the same
as gbt3
i think it's very impressive right it's
an information retrieval system right
and it's very impressive when right you
are typing something in like for like as
it exists on the internet i put a leak
code question in there which wasn't
publicly available and it was useless it
didn't do anything
right right i mean you can easily trip
it i mean obviously if you if you write
if you ask for a novel algorithm or a
novel function this thing is not writing
code let's let's be clear like like the
gpt3 is not really generating code and
code new text
but the stitching of stuff that it saw
in different places together is really
impressive i mean it it it doesn't add
apples and oranges it really adds apples
with apples that's the impressive part
so
tech wise
technology wise we know what's happening
this thing has seen
billions of lines of code and but the
matching is impressive if you dig deep
into the technology
you're going to be disappointed but it
looks impressive i i was like
you know
there were moments where i was like wow
what the hell right it's uh
but i doubt it would i i doubt that if
you ask for a
novel function that
even if someone wrote it somewhere but
some exotic function that we need every
day
it's not going to generate code this
thing does not generate code as long as
they sell it the right way and they
don't
you know embellish things beyond uh
because i saw stuff online that's really
ridiculous i mean
uh ai can now write code on its own yeah
don't say stuff but i think this is it
there's cognitive dissonance because as
an information retrieval system i think
it's to their credit but as an ai system
something that can reason abstractly and
generalize from a small amount of
information to something completely
different
it's not even knocking on the door
like the the interesting thing is as you
said the amount of regularity there is
in the world we live in
um most of the functions people want to
write are the same
there's surprisingly little novelty but
just like with tesla's self-driving cars
when you're driving out in the country
and a horse goes in front of your car or
a parade of ducks
right these are edge cases and
maybe in the coding scenario it doesn't
matter
right well look i mean it's the old uh
80 20
but but uh
in in
in something like automatic programming
it's that 20 percent that i i want i
mean
the 80 percent is now with our ides and
with our frameworks and
it's already there i mean like what's
the difference
dragging a table in and dotnet i mean
you can also create a huge database by
dragging tables and making
so or or saying create a table and text
probably visually it's even easier so
it's it's writing
it's coming up with solutions for me
that i like
gee how do you write a function like
this
no if if that's what you're looking for
and now forget it there's no intuitive
creativity at all this is fetching this
is a massive information retrieval an
impressive
massive information retrieval machine
in this case the information is code
but because of the scale and because of
the sheer size of this thing
it's impressive it looks like you know
i can get you code relevant to what
you're asking
and because it's language to code
it looks flashy it looks like you know
hey i'm i'm writing a command in english
and out comes code so it
but
there's very little
that is relevant to ai here let's be
clear i mean it's
this is an ir machine and in this case
code and it's not actually new
people thought about uh doing uh
information table on massive class
libraries back in the days when oro was
and they thought of writing business
objects that can cover pretty much
everything they try to come up with
standards and and then all you do in the
end is retrieve the relevant object and
use it and there you go
obviously
real life didn't work out like that but
so this is uh an information retrieval
for relevant snippets of code but yeah
on on the ai side
uh automatic programming is still a
dream exactly so just the the closing
thoughts um
i i couldn't use this myself i don't
think it would it would save me any time
it's only really useful in the form from
scratch
uh regime right so you start with a
blank slate it produces some code for
you
to use this thing incrementally on an
existing code base in the context of a
software engineering lifecycle can't
really see that happening
but yeah it's it's like the old ide
where you can
you can generate the skeleton of
something and you know in few
clicks and drag and drop and then you
have
some code generated just a basic
skeleton an empty shell
so this yeah this will help you
look it will be also useful i can see it
useful to someone who's
not quite the experienced programmer
that
probably
uh others i mean
they
it will help them to see how things
look like underneath so you know you you
uh especially in you in building a ui
let's say oh then there should be an uh
there should be an event for the button
so okay it will basically it's showing
them sample code it's it's cool you know
it's like uh
if you're a beginner
and you try something unique that you
never tried before this thing will give
you sample code
right so then oh you say ah
i need i need an event here to capture
the okay
uh in that sense it's cool it it it has
some places where it can be used
like i can see it in
in training or even in high school
programming uh courses like oh look guys
this is what a tape this is how you
create a table so let's say you want to
create a table
for a customer with name age okay you
see how it happens the the attributes
are
slotted this way so it's it's a nice way
to see sample code
i can imagine several uses for it i
hey folks i hope you enjoyed the episode
sorry for the delay on the jeff hawkins
episode i promise i'll release it on
friday
it's just taking a very long time for us
to produce that episode peace out